en sport c'est fini pour le tbb battu
par chaumont en quarts de finale en
match retour
les tourangeaux sont donc éliminés de la
course au titre de champion de france
un espoir déçu mais presque logique au
vu de la saison chaotique du club des
blessures un capitaine qui se fait la
malle et l'aco vide qui s'était invité
malgré elle bref une saison à oublier
comme nous l'expliquent lucas chopin
c'en est terminé pour le tours volley
ball le club achève sa saison à la
cinquième place de la ligue à 100 titres
de champions et avec un goût amer c'est
une saison frustrante
on est tous venus ici pour gagner un
titre et on avait cette ambition je
pense que c'était une ambition qu'on
avait le droit d'avoir et au final on a
la frustration sur tout ce qui s'est
passé au cours de cette saison qui a été
loin d'être un long fleuve tranquille et
ça a été compliqué frustrant une année
ponctuée de difficultés blessure crise
sanitaire tirage défavorable en ligue
des champions mais qu'il y aura surtout
été marquée par le transfert du
capitaine nathan woods mba en pleine
saison et par l'annoncé du départ du
coach hubert henno pour nantes l'an
prochain pour la direction du tvb la
saison est à oublier
je suis surtout déçu pour les joueurs
qui se sont pour certains vraiment très
très investi ça a été une année
difficile pour eux avec beaucoup de
changements beaucoup de rebondissements
des départs des arrivées pas une année
très simple dont je suis surtout déçu
pour eux sur l'investissement qu'ils ont
qu'il ce qu'ils ont donné on n'a pas été
en capacité de remplir une partie de nos
objectifs
pascal foussard garde pourtant on est
optimiste sur la saison prochaine
le tvb prendra un nouveau départ dès
jeudi avec l'annoncé de son nouvel
entraîneur